guests are due to arrive in 20 minutes
he doesn't know not an actual video he
doesn't oh you guys here for the wedding
- a little nervous
hi I'm Ryan Vergara by the way nice to
meet you hey I'm aria
and I love love although I've actually
never been to a proper wedding I've
always wanted to I've always wanted to
experience the magic and the romance of
it all
so yesterday I decided why not try
crashing one this weekend now my buddies
over at yes theory they tried doing this
a couple of years ago didn't work out
quite so well for them okay yeah hey
buddy hi I heard that you're gonna try
and sneak into a wedding
I mean I've kind of done a lot of
different sneaking in operations and
wedding was definitely the most awkward
one I've ever done because it's so
personal you should ask for the
permission right away so I'm learning
from their mistakes and I actually spent
all day yesterday calling different
wedding vendors to secretly try and find
a bride that would be okay with me
a complete stranger crashing her wedding
at the last minute my name is fernanda
padrone
this is fernando padrone fernando
padrone and I am catering the wedding
handling the flowers there should be a
wedding taking place at your venue this
weekend is that correct it took ages it
was very stressful but eventually I
found an amazing couple named charity
and Paul who are up for it that said
even though the couple knows we're
coming I want to still have some fun and
see how well I can blend in so I made
sure that nobody else at the wedding
knows who we are Who I am
and we'll see how this goes each side of
Jack yeah I'm excited
should I do a British accent all right
we're gonna get changed
[Music]
Oxford nursing from Oxford isn't that a
school that's a city the schools in the
town of Oxfordshire yes yes are due to
arrive in 20 minutes my first piece of
advice ideally if you do go with
somebody else just split up I'm gonna
drop you off first they have a wedding
photographer that you could connect with
because you're the videographer right
and he doesn't know I'm not an actual
video he doesn't alright see you man I'm
walking right now I feel like my accent
sounds really bad oh wow this is really
beautiful
oh wow there's gonna be so many comments
just roasting me because I don't sound
believable at all
hello I'm here for a charity and Paul's
yes sir Desilu hey Jack good how are you
good to meet you nice to meet you yeah
we're shooting the wedding are you guys
here for the wedding too thank you very
much
[Music]
well I see you jack a little nervous
hi I'm Ryan Vergara by the way really
nice to meet you my second piece of
advice is just walk around mingle that
wasn't a wedding list I can just walk in
my god and just blend in Kelly diamond
nice to meet you Kevin wind nice to meet
you to make this a memorable experience
I've set myself three goals to
accomplish at this wedding firstly I'd
like to make some friends that take at
least three pictures with them secondly
I want to dance with someone fun and
lastly I have to deliver a speech well
Ivan I'm no charity for for ages I've
actually never met sherry before
I'm on time Apollo sighs yeah I probably
don't stick with some one person for too
long because they might start poking
holes at your story well I'm gonna sit
over there but that's me all these
people are you gonna talk to my ask you
questions and you're gonna have to know
how to answer them charity oh I think
she I think she speaks some hey man I
would love I would love to show thank
you what was your contact information
this family has been very very nice to
me I just got invited to visit them in
China I gotta take a picture with you
guys I just want to make sure I'm y'all
capturing memories you know here I'll
come back with you guys
perfect thank you all so much
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all it's like happy for me
sneaking into a wedding was probably one
of the most awkward difficult
experiences because it's just not easy
man it's such a personal events for
these people that you're always kind of
walking on ice it is my great honor to
be the first to introduce Paul and
charity as husband and wife it's nice I
was your name really good I've been
surprised by how emotional this day has
made me a little bit you know I guess
that's sweet seeing all these people
come together with the celebrations now
underway I step up my attempts to make
some friends have fun I mean we'd be the
kindest most fun guy there James
sane timid a nice you just want to be
good vibes so that people don't question
why you're there basically like nobody's
gonna want to kick out a guy that's just
bringing goodbye oh your pump oh it's so
nice to finally meet you I've heard so
many good things well Charlie wheat I
want to school with her for events oh
you're
yeah go Bruins like get small pieces of
information and then build your big
narrative through that I know charity
back from my UCLA yeah I feel like I
sound like a psychopath but I'm taking
this stuff but you really got to believe
in your own story for why you're there
and just back that up hard I had some
bad grades so I may afford some
documents
faculty found out remove about that I'm
crazy I'm that crazy I work in the strip
club business I've always cheap Club now
I'm working in oil you are for free I'll
get you all to lap down to zero on made
some friends I love leaf leaf what a
great guy you come to a pole and charity
go there be this tune I would love to
take a picture with you memory there we
go
charity fall thank you so much for
inviting me
everything is beautiful you guys
literally look what's behind me if what
Papa keeping a picture the three of us -
I love a Mary the three of us what type
of cheese you think this is probably
ricotta it's gonna be great
are you shaking cold as dinner begins I
realize that
unfortunately I'm the only one that
doesn't have a designated seat
after I wait for everyone who gets
seated I quickly decided to act drunk
and sit down at an empty chair hoping no
one gets suspicious very very nicely and
it works so that's a good bathroom this
is actually my first wedding I live into
money before and genuinely I can say I
love I love being oh no it's very nice
did you say
I'm very glad to be here I've never been
to a wedding before I'm 27 I'm having a
great time I'm so glad to meet you guys
I don't want to come up what's you guys
get back guys want to come say hi my
cabbage we're not having sex in here
[Music]
is anyone out there
[Music]
as the reception starts going into the
night I realize I don't have too much
time left to make my speech but first
congratulations to you both again that
was out of all I just want to thank you
too just sincerely as well because
absolutely yeah I'm so great to be a
part of it today I'm having a great time
this was better than I could've hoped
for my first wedding not only the nice
to experience like a proper wedding but
it's really nice to be able to see one
with a couple really truly love what
another charity I give you this ring as
a part of me and doing this I take you
as my wife good luck man it's not easy
but I think you'll have fun yeah it was
a lot of fun my first wedding I don't
really know anyone here
because I kind of I kind of basically
crashed this wedding
[Applause]
thank you but I want to say I've had an
amazing time here a wise movie once said
that true love is the sole recognition
of this kind of point in another and I
can only say that being here with all of
you the love I felt between charity and
pause well as all of you towards the two
of them have been so true
and so real that I thank you for looking
me share this day with all of you and I
go in hope that if I'm lucky enough to
get married one day it's half as
wonderful as this day has been so thank
you
and here's a toast cheers to the happy
couple charity and Paul thank you bye
I do have to apologize to your dad I
told him that I want a strip club I may
have promised him some lap dances oh my
god you got a feeling I was a wedding -
yeah I thought like straight - seriously
like Riley didn't
I thought you might have been broke but
then I saw you two target
I'm in love with Paul sadly oh yeah it's
great read it I was lovely so glad I was
great oh so if anything the one thing
I'll say good night if I have a new
friendship with me
[Music]
let's hear it one more time everyone for
mr. and mrs. we're on fire
[Applause]
[Music]
it's me jack from England